Gregg if you had to pick somebody out
and I know you watched every every
minute of it
right you bet who would you say one well
I'd say the most memorable would be
Tulsi she Kamala - Kamala
I mean if Joe Biden was Tonya Harding
Tulsi was Shawn Eckhart and he just
hitting camel in the knee or it was
basically Nancy Kerrigan and you I mean
it was the most memorable thing I do
have a wait a sec who's Sean ackard
because I thought and I'm gonna get
roundly criticized but she was a fashion
statement last night that you cannot
comment on her clothing it because it's
white Juan no so you know what there's a
couple of things one I don't like it
audience I don't like the audience
reaction to things because they react to
what is interesting or exciting and not
not what is important so when somebody
Zing's somebody you get this uh like the
like the kool-aid line the court used
wasn't that creative or interesting but
it felt like it needed applause to your
point in xx in 2009 President Obama was
seen as a progressive hero ten years
later he's now considered a Republican
and Obamacare is a white ring Hawai
twing plot but the attacks on Obama
reflect an actual fact the Trump's only
been president for three years the major
problems that they're discussing whether
it's immigration or health care happened
and death let's talk deficits and drugs
for decades so it just seems like maybe
they're right that they have to talk
about they have to go past Trump he's
only been there for three years not even
that